I have no respect for you. Not
apologizing to you cult followers and I
got receipts. So don't think I'm here to
apologize to any of you. I'm just trying
to make sure I'm apologizing to the true
Orthodox. Amen.
Come on. Okay. The true
Orthodox, those true Orthodox, Eastern
Orthodox or Antro Orthodox who even and
I got receipts. I got articles that
there are Orthodox who call out Jay Dyer
and his Oh, yeah. followers and tell
Orthodox to avoid them. I got the
receipt. Hold on, brother. Let me just
go to Rumble. Rumble, welcome. Sorry.
This is an impromptu session. It's been
one of the worst years in Lent for me,
man. I'm getting fat, falling to food,
and the attacks been like never before.
Now,
brother, is it true JP is with Jay Dyer?
They sent me a screenshot where
apparently he had sent some comments to
the channel and Jay Dyier repeated them.
Now, uh, unlike other people, I want to
be very clear, he was not there on the
video or the audio, but he had sent some
messages and Jay and Jay Dyer read them
aloud. Read them? You mean and they're
making fun of orbs? Is this the same Jay
Dyer who's into aliens and conspiracies
and all kinds of conspiracies? And I
could tell why JP would be happy. JP and
cut him. I would say I'd be happy too.
He got Jay Dyer to use speirious texts
when he pressed him. Yeah. You mean the
same J JP who caught Jay Dyer for
quoting forgeries. Now brother JP got
him the other day behind the scenes
because I've tried to be respectful to
Jay Dyer. I should say gay liar but it's
the gloves are off. I'm gonna have to
take him out as well. I'm done with him.
I try to be nice, but you said to me
when JP went on his channel. You said
it. I'm a witness before God. Jay Dyer
humiliated himself because he quoted
forgeries and JP is going to
embarrass him. What happened? I sure
did. In fact, I saw the full clip. JP
has been asking for certain texts for a
long time in terms of intercession of
the saints and he went over to Jay's
channel and they had a back and forth
and he began to press Jay. Number one,
uh, kudos to you JP. Jay wasn't able to
give him any early information with the
parameters that JP wanted. Instead, all
that Jay Dire gave him were spirious
texts is what he gave him. Sperious
text, right? spirious text that didn't
even fulfill what JP was asking him for.
So here you have Jay Dyer making fun of
you saying that you don't know church
history when Jay Dyer has been caught
using spirious texts over and over and
over. And let me say one thing. Uh I saw
a little clip a little while ago, Jay,
where Jay was calling my papacy
arguments low low tier. Jay, well we can
debate the papacy. No, that's Yeah. And
let me let me say one thing, Jay. It's
very interesting that you reached out to
Cameron Raker. You reached out to him
about two weeks ago wanting to debate.
You reached out to him real big and
tough wanting to debate against the
Catholic. Well, Cameron reached out to
me because we're buddies. I told
Cameron, "Here's everything I'll debate
him on." And I didn't limit the topics.
I threw them all out there. Filioqui,
papacy, Immaculate Conception, Canon. I
don't care. I gave Canon a laundry list
of topics. Cameron went back to Jay.
Once he told Jay that I was up to
debate, Jay said he'd debate anybody
other than me. Can I confirm? Hey, gay
liar. Gay liar. I want everyone to see
this. Say gay liar. There you go. I got
the
receipts. I'm going to play eventually.
I'm going to play. See, gay liar. I just
called them out.
You remember when I said I was going to
set up a discussion, a panel discussion
between Gay Liar and whoever he wanted?
Oh, yeah. He was bring Petros. I told
you, you said, "Let's do it. You're
going to come on. Who are you going to
bring with you?" I was going to bring my
brother uh Eric Kabara and the Titan
Elijah Yasi. I said, "We're ready. We're
willing." Said, "I don't I even told you
he can bring Ubie. I don't care who the
other guy is that he wants to bring
anyone, any scholar, anyone he wants to
bring to discuss the papacy. Elijah was
ready. Now Elisha, I don't know if he's
here. He can bear bear witness. He was
ready. Eric Bar were ready. We were
ready for a threeon three debate on the
papac from the Bible and church history.
I'm a witness. Receipts don't lie. I'm
here. Elijah, anytime, brother. See, I'm
ready. See, brother, I'm gonna reach out
to your brother soon. And I know I'm
going to I've been falling behind. Now
guys, you know who backed down? Receipts
don't lie. You know what Gay Liar told
me? He said Ubie Petros won't do it with
you because they don't like to debate
you. I got the receipts, Gay Liar. And
look how loyal and faithful I am. See,
this is my fault. You never exposed it.
I'm the guy who tries to be loyal even
to people who attack my position. Yep.
I'm the guy. I said nothing. I zipped
it. Yep. I didn't mention that. I want
to embarrass his team. So then Jay, or I
should say Gay Liar said, "Well, we can
do presentations." I wasn't for
presentations. You know why, brother? He
didn't want to be He didn't want to be
pressed by me. He instead said, "Too
mean, too nasty." So he said he'll do a
presentation alone and then I can
respond because William Albbrick is too
mean. He's too nasty. Look, Jade, you
reached out to Cameron, willing to
debate anyone. When Cameron told you
that I was up to debate you, you ran for
the hills. Jay, enough. Jay, if you want
to debate the papacy, you know where to
find me, but you've blocked me anywhere.
This is what we're going to do. Jay,
I've got low tier arguments. We're going
to debate the purgatorial texts at
Florence, the Florentine text from Mark
of Ephesus. I know you're not aware of
them, but guess what? I've translated
them from the Greeks in the English.
There's a big difference between me and
you, Jay. You're playing Connect For and
I'm doing real theology work. We'll
debate the words of Mark of Ephesus and
the papacy that aren't in English right
now, but I can read them in Greek. Jay,
enough running. Exactly. You put my name
on your mouth in a post, you better be
ready to debate. Pines with Aquinus or
go to Cameron. You are a big enough boy
to reach out to Cameron for any debate
against anyone but Albrri. Go back to
Cameron. Cameron is willing and ready to
host a debate. Enough with the running,
Jay. Enough with the lies. Enough with
the excuses. Come to the table and
debate. But I promise you one thing.
We're going to be debating the critical
texts of your titans. Palamos in the
Greek. Mark of Ephesus in the Greek.
Brienos in the Greek. I know your own
saints better than you know them. You
better come to the table and debate.
So here I want to ask you a question.
And by the way, I'm going to explain
what I didn't want to do to the
presentation. They said that when
debates were set up that you pretty much
duck tail. Have you ever done that?
Never have I done that to anyone. Jay
Dary challenged me to debate and
promptly blocked me on Twitter. I've got
the screenshots. Elijah Yasi is here
years back. Elijah told Jay, "Debbate me
and William two on two on the Immaculate
Conception." And Elijah Yasi is a
witness. Jay said he declined to face
this. Elijah, come on. Been declining
for years.
Guys, do not come up yet. I'll open up
Q&A a minute. Don't come up. Elijah, you
can come up. Okay. So now for the world
to
hear. Now before I go there, William,
can you help me understand if I'm new to
the faith and I took a step of faith to
enter the Catholic Church and I need to
learn about the papacy and the fil
because those aren't my bread and
butter. But when it comes to the Trinity
and the early Christians view of the
Trinity, I don't know if Jay thinks he
knows more than me. I'll pulverize him
because gay liar I think you forgot you
invited me to help you refute Muslim
metatabo. Do you remember? You carried
the whole thing. You put him on your
back and you carried the whole and I'm
the one who let you know the church
fathers remember gay liar. You forgot
but we got receipts. It's recorded. You
carried the whole way. And you know
what? You know what Jay? You know what I
had to do Jay? After during your cross
examination when you allowed Jake the
Muslim to pummel you on St. Justin and
you said St. Justin had a heretical
christologology. I had to come back and
clean up your mess, Jay. Enough of you
being the big bad wolf. Nobody is scared
of you, Jay. No one is scared of you,
Jay. In fact, we don't take you
seriously, Jay. Brother, I want to ask
you a question. You know, I don't know
much about the filio in the papacy or
essence and energies distinction.
Now, I don't know if you know, I know
it's late for you, so I'm going to go
through in text. Why did he manifest and
foam at the mouth in the comment
section? Because he's playing the
victim. He calls me out of nowhere. I'm
in a live stream, guys. It's in the live
stream. You scum, ortho, sisses or
sissies, cancer on the Orthodox church.
May the Lord rebuke you and protect the
church from
you. Why is he reaching out to me on my
liveream? On the live stream, brother,
demolishing Alex Okconor. It's there.
You'll see. Out of nowhere, I get this
message. Look, I saw it. And people were
people are even baffled. Look, I want to
be very clear for the audience. I don't
know what happened. Let me be very clear
on my channel. I've got tons of Orthodox
MS near and dear brothers. I work side
by side with top Eastern Orthodox
scholars, theologians. I love my
Orthodox brethren, but the way this man
acts is vile. This man is not a lover of
Christ. He does not love Christ. I'd be
shocked if he went to mass. He's a cult
leader. He does not represent Eastern
Orthodoxy. I love my Orthodox brothers
and sisters. This gentleman does not
represent Eastern Orthodox, brother.
Here, this is what happened, guys. It's
in the live stream. Here's the text. Out
of
nowhere, how about you and Alrech, come
debate me on the energies and the tribe.
Out of nowhere, brother. Okay, William.
William, brother, guys, it's live. Go
watch it. What an I'm destroying Alex.
I'm getting this message. I'm like, what
is this guy talking about? Then he says
this. Watch here, guys. We got receipts.
Gay
liar. How are Protestants the best on
Trinity? Oh, we got gay liar here. You
want to bring Oh, I think he's live on
his channel. Gay liar. We're challenging
to debate. I think he wants to go live
on his channel to get more
subscribers. So, I don't know if I want
to bring him up because I don't want him
to be famous with clips. Gay liar, we're
challenged you to formal debate. Not on
your on your channel. Yeah. Right. Yep.
So here your crowd is listening. Will
you accept a formal debate? What are the
topics you want to select? Yes or no?
Let's do papacy. Papacy. Bible church
history. Let's do purgatory. Let's do
canon. Your hilarious arguments on
Trulo. Jay, people are their tummies are
bursting from laughter on your arguments
that the cannon was decided at Trulo.
You're a neophite, Jay. You're a
neophite. Purgatory, canon, Immaculate
Conception. Agree to the debate, Jay.
Pick a neutral moderator if you want.
Pick a neutral form, a platform if you
want. Enough, Jay. Enough acting like a
big guy. Here's another thing, Jay. I
also want to debate you on this. You're
insulting Sam, saying Sam doesn't know
about dieting. Jay, I want you to come
and tell the audience why you were a
snake oil salesman pedalling fake
testosterone building chalk. We'll talk
about the ingredients in chalk. We'll
talk about testosterone building
supplements. Remember when you promoted
that? You remember that, Jay? I want to
talk about that with you. You remember
that? So, gay liar, we're going to call
you out standing for truth if you're too
scared or even point, oh, but they're
too Catholic. Get ready to do formal
debates. Get ready to go live. Not do
live stream where you cut off and try to
dominate like a good Muslim. I will be
live tomorrow, Jay. Whatever you say
about the papacy tonight, I'm going to
shred it tomorrow. Jay, we're going to
see you on a neutral platform.